the sun monster is gonna kill us all the
day after tomorrow unless we give all
our money and power away to the limbs
seriously I know that people have warned
about that before but this time they're
super duper serious guys it's real
that's true
all of it and to get their point across
they're destroying beautiful works of
art
anyway we've got an assortment of the
absolute greatest attacks on Beauty by
climate junky Libs uh and I'm gonna have
to pick the absolute best one this video
is brought To Us by
expressvpn more from them later first
let's take it away
limbs are spraying
orange paint
on a nice building
and the sidewalk where'd they get that
fire truck from
[Music]
they sprayed 1800 liters of fake blood
that's what it is oh I get it and then
it's sprayed everywhere and looks like
it got all over them when they lost
control of the fire hose
there's a deep metaphor right there just
these guys yes they defaced a beautiful
thing but mostly they just made a big
mess of themselves that is that is what
happens if you commit your life to
Liberal activism you will deface the
good the true and the Beautiful to some
degree but mostly you'll just get
yourself covered up in blood they
couldn't even spring for real pigs bro
it's only pain
[Applause]
[Music]
so I know that they're in a European
country here what is it France you know
what the French call
what they've got that which sounds kind
of like a French ambulance and the way I
know that they're in one of these
European countries while they're in
France is not because of the accent it's
because they did that thing that the
soccer players do where the soccer
players when some guy would look at them
the wrong way they just go
oh I I think I broke my leg ah they fly
they flop on the ground and they they
ride and pretend to be in pain so I'm
not surprised that the climate activists
are huge soccer fans
security
just stop oil activists
art or life
is it worth more than food worth more
than Justice
are you more concerned about the
protection of a painting or the
protection of our planet and people the
cost of living crisis is part of the
cost of oil crisis
[Music]
they can't even afford to heat a tin of
soup they can't afford to eat a tin of
soup that I'm just gonna throw on this
van Gogh over here yeah sorry sorry
family that happened at the National
Gallery in London they threw a can of
tomato soup on the van Gogh painting it
happened coincidentally like one day
before I arrived in London for the
baptism of Candice owens's baby for whom
I Am The Godfather
and so we land and then I almost
immediately ran to the National Gallery
and I I found a spoon in one of the
local cafes and I snuck the spoon in so
that I could take a picture with the van
Gogh holding up the spoon and smiling
now the the van Gogh was not covered in
soup anymore because very wisely the
museum curators covered these paintings
in glass the people came in they got rid
of the wacko climate people and then
they just they cleaned up the glass A
little bit I was not able to get any
soup at the National Gallery the van
Gogh continues I love to she says what's
more important the painting or the
people
man does not live by soup Alone Lady the
people they won't be able to afford the
suit that I'm spilling everywhere man
does not live by bread and soup alone
[Music]
man lives by every word that is uttered
by God man also lives by Beauty man also
lives by Art man also lives by culture
and the the libs what they're doing is
destroying culture destroying Beauty
destroying the intelligibility of our
world for what we don't even get soup in
the end
[Music]
oh there we go
there we go more soap how do you feel
better
how do you feel when you see something
beautiful and price was being apparently
destroyed before he arrives
he glued himself
do you feel outraged I feel pity for you
I feel pity for for whatever's gone
wrong in your education and your
perception of the world to deface a
beautiful portrait of Scarlett Johansson
like that is so outrageous what is going
on also pointlessly because the painting
was not was not destroyed you know the
the old kind of radicals they would blow
stuff up and murder people and launch
revolutions and everything and that was
truly evil but those guys had the
courage of their convictions these guys
it's all just LARPing it's all fake
they're not even destroying the
paintings
sorry it's fun though right good thank
God they're not destroying the paintings
thank God they're not hurting anybody
but it's all just fake they're just
they're just doing it they get a little
bit of attention they're egged on by the
global corporations that they pretend to
hate anyway it's all just a big LARP to
take money and power away from all of us
and to deface a little bit of Beauty in
the process which our liberal
establishment's been after for a very
very long time we've got to protect
ourselves you got to protect your data
think for a moment about the idea that a
single company controls 90 of internet
searches runs your email service and
gets to track everything you do on your
smartphone it is time to put a layer of
protection between your online activity
and these Tech juggernauts that is why I
would strongly recommend you check out
expressvpn think about how much of your
life is on the internet every site you
visit video you watch message you send
gets tracked and data mined but when you
use expressvpn on your devices the
software hides your IP address something
big Tech can use to personally identify
you expressvpn encrypts 100 of your
internet data to keep you safe from
hackers and eavesdroppers on your
network what I like most about
expressvpn is how easy it is to use you
download the app on your phone or
computer you tap one button and you're
protected that's that expressvpn does
all of this without slowing your
connection so stop handing over your
personal data by visiting expressvpn.com
Michael YT the letter y letter t
expresvpn.com
Michael YT expressvpn.com Michael YT to
learn more okay give me more crazy
climate Labs it's climate activists
decided to break into a shipping yard
and glue themselves to an oil tanker
they were advocating for the Stop of all
new fossil fuel production but something
the protesters didn't realize is that
they glued themselves to a tanker full
of vegetable cooking oil
that was so dumb witch In fairness is
pretty much indistinguishable from motor
oil they call it vegetable cooking
that's called seed oils is what it is
it's very bad for you at least that's
what they tell me on the internet seed
oils are some of the worst things your
body can consume but anyway that's
hilarious it's just so it's so classic
look at these dopes they go in they
throw soup on paintings they protest
gasoline they scream and yell and make a
nuisance they think they're helping what
are they really doing they're just
furthering the agenda of the liberal
establishment to take more money and
power away from us pay off their cronies
and the green energy industry don't help
a soul among the great massive people
okay next one a man and two women
stormed the stage of the show Let's
Dance during its live finale they threw
Yellow powder across the floor we're
holding it up
as you can see they're a jib operator
quickly smashed the male protester in
the face with his camera before security
took him away the show as they say went
on with the dancing Duo not letting it
get in their way
there's a rule of game shows it's a rule
of politics and a rule of life
if you play stupid games you will very
likely win stupid prizes
and that is what the climate activists
have just learned so I say
no it's kind of funny
if they fail to act we're going to lose
our chance we're going to lose our
chance all life on Earth will lose its
chance like these dead mer folk that we
have represents sea life that's died
since I was born 50 of ocean life has
died everybody dies lady good grief I
like that it's mer folk mermaid
these people they even have to trans the
mermaids they can't even let the
mermaids Remain the right sex but I like
this one more than I like the other ones
the merfolk lives matter protest is
overtly mythical so instead of them
having a bunch of dolphins or sharks or
something I guess sharks would be kind
of scary
foreign
global warming is killing the Sharks
people would probably applaud that but
instead of doing that they have just
mythical creatures not even the normal
mythical creatures not even the pretty
mermaids but the mer men I don't know
that's not gonna that's not gonna Rouse
my soul it's not going to cause my sword
to LEAP from my Scabbard to go avenge
their deaths on the sun monster I'll
probably just look away and do something
else what's my favorite one is no
question no question it's the Murphy
lives matter don't you forget it see you
next time
foreign